C'est la veille de Noël, en 1968.
Le vaisseau spatial Apollo 8 a complété avec succès
ses trois premières orbites autour de la Lune.
que les hommes voyagent autour de la Terre, au-delà de l'orbite basse.
Au quatrième passage du vaisseau,
la Terre émerge lentement
et apparaît au-dessus de l'horizon de la Lune.
L'astronaute Bill Anders, excité,
demande à ses compagnons où est la caméra.
Il s'empare du Hasselblad, le pointe vers la fenêtre, appuie sur l'obturateur
et prend quelques-unes des photos les plus importantes de tous les temps :
le Lever de la Terre.
De retour sain et sauf quelques jours plus tard,
on questionna l'équipage sur la mission.
Anders donna cette fameuse réponse :
« Nous sommes avons voyagé vers la Lune,
mais en fait, nous avons découvert la Terre. »
Qu'ont-ils ressenti, lui et ses compagnons d'équipage,
à cet instant incroyable ?
Dans une étude publiée juste l'année dernière,
une équipe de chercheurs à l'Université de Pennsylvanie
qui ont eu l'opportunité de voir la Terre à partir de l'espace.
Leur analyse a révélé trois sentiments communs :
le premier : une appréciation plus grande de la beauté de la Terre ;
le deuxième : un sentiment renforcé de connexion à tous les êtres vivants ;
le troisième : une émotion inattendue et souvent bouleversante.
Les chercheurs pensent que voir la Terre de très loin
incite une personne à développer de nouveaux cadres cognitifs
pour comprendre ce qu'elle est en train de voir.
Ils croient que ces astronautes ont été transformés pour toujours
par cette nouvelle vision, cette nouvelle perspective,
cette nouvelle vérité visuelle.
Cette sensation est communément appelée : « l'effet de surplomb ».
Seules 558 personnes ont été dans l'espace.
558 personnes ont eu l'opportunité d'admirer la vue en surplomb,
de s'émerveiller de notre planète flottant dans une mer infinie d'obscurité.
Et si ce nombre grandissait ?
Il y a trois ans, j'ai commencé ma propre mission
pour essayer de faire ressentir cette sensation d'immensité et de beauté
à beaucoup plus de gens,
en utilisant juste un petit ordinateur et mon petit appartement à New York.
C'est donc en 2013 que j'ai lancé Daily Overview.
J'ai utilisé, chaque jour, l'imagerie satellite
pour créer une vue aérienne élargie de notre planète.
Plus de 1 000 de ces images ont été créées jusqu'à présent,
et plus de 600 000 personnes
reçoivent cette dose quotidienne de perspective.
Je crée l'image en sélectionnant des photos
dans les énormes archives d'une société d'imagerie spatiale nommée Digital Globe.
Ils exploitent une constellation de cinq satellites,
chacun de la taille d'une ambulance environ,
constamment en train de prendre des photos de la Terre,
orbitant à 28 000 km/h.
Alors, qu'est-ce que cela veut dire ?
Chacun de ces satellites possède une caméra
possédant une distance focale de 16 mètres.
C'est environ 290 fois plus qu'une caméra DSLR
équipée d'une lentille standard de 55 millimètres.
Donc, si nous pouvions fixer un de leurs satellites
sur le toit de ce théâtre à Oxford,
nous pourrions prendre la photo d'un ballon de football,
parfaitement claire,
sur un terrain de foot à Amsterdam.
C'est à 450 km.
C'est une technologie incroyablement puissante.
J'ai décidé au début de ce projet
d'utiliser cette incroyable technologie pour me concentrer sur les lieux
où les hommes ont affecté la planète.
En tant qu'espèce,
nous creusons et grattons la Terre à la recherche de ressources ;
nous produisons de l'énergie ;
nous élevons des animaux et cultivons pour nous nourrir ;
nous construisons des villes ; nous nous déplaçons ;
nous créons des déchets.
Et en faisant toutes ces choses,
nous façonnons des paysages terrestres, marins et urbains
avec de plus en plus de contrôle et d'impunité.
Gardant ceci à l'esprit,
je voudrais partager avec vous quelques-unes de mes vues aériennes.
Ici, nous voyons des cargos et des pétroliers
qui attendent devant l'entrée du port de Singapour.
Cette installation est au deuxième rang des ports mondiaux
en termes de tonnage total,
transbordant un cinquième des conteneurs dans le monde
et la moitié de l'approvisionnement annuel de pétrole brut.
En regardant attentivement cette photo, vous verrez plein de petites taches.
Ce sont, en fait, des vaches dans un parc d'engraissement
à Summerfield, au Texas.
Quand les vaches atteignent un poids particulier,
environ 300 kilos,
elles sont amenées ici pour suivre un régime spécialisé.
Au cours des trois à quatre mois suivants, les vaches gagnent 180 kg supplémentaires
avant d'être envoyées à l'abattoir.
Vous vous interrogez peut-être sur cette piscine, au sommet, là.
Cette couleur vient d'une unique combinaison de fumier, produits chimiques,
et une espèce d'algue particulière qui pousse dans l'eau stagnante.
Ceci est la mine de fer du Mount Whaleback,
dans la région de Pilbara en Australie occidentale,
une belle mais effrayante cicatrice à la surface de la Terre.
Du minerai de fer extrait mondialement,
98 % est utilisé pour fabriquer de l'acier
et constitue donc un élément majeur dans la construction de bâtiments,
d'automobiles ou d'appareils comme votre lave-vaisselle ou votre réfrigérateur.
Ceci est un concentrateur d'énergie solaire, à Séville.
Donc, cette installation contient 2 650 miroirs
qui sont disposés en cercles concentriques
autour d'une tour de 140 mètres de haut située à son centre.
Au sommet de la tour, il y a une capsule de sel fondu
chauffée par les rayons de lumière ascendants des miroirs situés dessous.
De là, le sel circule vers un réservoir de stockage sous terre,
où il produit de la vapeur qui fait tourner des turbines
et génère suffisamment d'électricité pour alimenter 70 000 foyers,
et contrebalance 30 000 tonnes de dioxyde de carbone émis chaque année.
Cette vue d'ensemble montre la déforestation à Santa Cruz, en Bolivie,
en limite des étendues intactes de forêt tropicale.
La déforestation dans ce pays a surtout été entraînée
par l'expansion de l'agriculture mécanisée et de l'élevage du bétail.
Alors que le pays tente de répondre
à la demande de sa population croissante et de les nourrir,
on a effectué une destruction sacrificielle de sa forêt tropicale.
On estime que le pays a perdu 4,5 millions d'acres de forêt tropicale
en une seule décennie, de 2000 à 2010.
C'est le quartier de l'Eixample à Barcelone.
La perspective aérienne peut être incroyablement utile
pour comprendre comment marchent les villes
et concevoir des solutions plus intelligentes d'urbanisme.
Et cela va devenir de plus en plus important
car on prévoit que 4,9 milliards de personnes
vivront dans les villes, dans le monde entier, d'ici à 2030.
Ce quartier de Barcelone se caractérise par son quadrillage rigoureux,
ses appartements à cours communes,
et ses intersections octogonales
qui permettent plus d'ensoleillement, une meilleure ventilation
et plus d'espaces de stationnement au niveau de la rue.
Ici, nous voyons ce modèle de grille, dans des circonstances très différentes.
Ceci est le camp de réfugiés de Dadaab, dans le nord du Kenya,
la plus grande installation de ce genre dans le monde.
Pour faire face à l'afflux de réfugiés fuyant la Somalie,
où il y a famine et conflits,
l'ONU a construit cette zone rayée, à gauche, appelée « l'extension LFO »
pour loger de plus en plus de réfugiés
qui occupent ces points blancs qui sont, en fait, des tentes
qui vont lentement remplir la zone au fil du temps.
Donc, si vous avez une de ces vues aériennes,
vous avez un moment dans le temps.
Si nous en avons deux, cependant,
nous pouvons raconter des histoires sur les changements dans le temps.
J'appelle cette fonction du projet « Juxtaposer »,
et nous allons partager quelques exemples avec vous maintenant.
Les champs de tulipes, aux Pays-Bas, fleurissent chaque année en avril.
Nous prenons donc une image faite en Mars, quelques semaines avant,
et la comparons à une prise quelques semaines plus tard.
Nous pouvons voir les fleurs s'épanouir dans cette magnifique cascade de couleurs.
On estime que les Néerlandais produisent annuellement 4,3 milliards de tulipes.
En 2015, deux barrages se sont effondrés
dans une mine de fer dans le sud-est du Brésil,
causant l'une des pires catastrophes environnementales
dans l'histoire du pays.
D'après les estimations, 62 millions de mètres cubes de déchets
ont été libérés quand les barrages ont lâché,
détruisant de nombreux villages dans la foulée,
dont Bento Rodrigues, vu ici avant ...
et après l'inondation.
Au final, 19 personnes ont été tuées dans cette catastrophe.
Un demi-million de personnes n'ont pas eu accès à l'eau potable
pendant une longue période.
Les déchets sont rapidement entrés dans la rivière Doce,
puis se sont déplacés sur 650 km, jusqu'à la mer,
tuant d'innombrables quantités de plantes et d'animaux au passage.
Enfin, voici une histoire liée à la crise en Syrie,
un conflit qui a coûté la vie à des centaines de milliers de personnes
et déplacé des millions.
Donc, ce morceau de désert est une vue de Mafraq, en Jordanie,
en 2011, l'année où le conflit a commencé.
Quand on la compare à une image prise cette année, en 2017,
nous voyons la construction du camp de réfugiés de Zaatari.
Donc, tout comme les astronautes d'Apollo 8
ont regardé la Terre s'élever sur le paysage lunaire pour la première fois,
jamais vous n'auriez pu imaginer
à quoi ressemblaient les endroits que je viens de vous montrer,
vus de l'espace.
Et si vous pouvez apprécier l'esthétique d'une image,
quand vous comprenez exactement ce que vous voyez,
il est possible que vous ayez des difficultés à continuer à l'aimer.
Et c'est cette tension que je veux créer avec mon travail.
Car je crois que c'est cette contemplation,
ce dialogue interne,
qui conduiront à plus d'intérêt pour notre planète
et plus d'attention à ce que nous lui faisons.
Je crois que regarder la Terre en surplomb,
est plus important, maintenant, que jamais.
Grâce à la technologie incroyable de ces caméras de haute altitude,
nous pouvons voir, surveiller et exposer
l'impact sans précédent que nous avons.
Que nous soyons scientifiques,
ingénieurs, décideurs politiques,
investisseurs, ou artistes,
si nous pouvons adopter une perspective plus large,
embrasser la vérité de ce qui se passe,
et envisager la santé à long terme de notre planète,
nous pouvons créer un avenir meilleur, plus sûr et plus intelligent
pour notre seule et unique maison.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)